[Music]
Gong's tumor is so large the doctors
worry its removal could cause fatal
hemorrhaging
and his weak organs could fail under the
stress of the operation
[Music]
she's relation to each other a greatest
fear for any surgeon is a patient dying
on the table and it will be insatiable
desire in Guang's case every stage of
the operation presents a risk to his
life don't you attend the marriage the
first step is to block the veins Iran's
tumor has stopped the blood flow for the
human
Cynthia then we feast the tumor and turn
it into a giant ice ball then the tumor
can be cut out freezing a tumor to
remove it more easily is called
cryoablation it's never been used to
treat a tumor the size of Wong's
[Music]
you are the killer to me
we have never done this kind of surgery
before me every step is an experiment
[Music]
Hansol comes it's like walking a
tightrope you never know where you might
fall
[Music]
- Louisville could I be really show so
when I was young other kids used to
laugh at one they used to call him
Elephant Man's so I didn't stop them I
think I was ashamed to be his brother
then when I left home I missed him so
much at night I used to cry myself to
sleep
[Music]